[Music]
foreign
so first you know I think that that
whole sentiment that Allah wants to keep
his followers in fear is is really
um a very contemporary one that has been
instilled even many many even many
um
probably from like certain cultural
perspectives and maybe even in in how
um
we we kind of uh sometimes we try to
make people to become more Pious we
address them in a way that where Allah
has looked at as simply this as one
attribute as as only one aspect of
himself uh as being a Punisher or
something of the sort and I think this
is problematic
um and I do see that there's a lot of
assumptions built into the question as
well and uh I don't know where the
sentiment is coming from necessarily but
I will try to address why I think it is
problematic so uh first I want to note
that so to get to the the bottom of the
issue here that in Islam non-muslims
are don't simply go to hell because
they're born non-muslims or because you
know they just happen to be non-muslims
they have to have the only reason they
go to hell is if they don't have a valid
excuse for example if they're if they're
not ignorant or or you know if if they
don't if they have no access to the
truth uh then of course Allah will show
Mercy to them right so it's not simply
based on your identity that a person
Goes to Hell Fire in fact the qurans say
it's very explicitly that Hellfire is
for the Arrogant for those who who who
who don't fear Allah they have no sense
of like
um humility
in their hearts for the truth right so
these individuals are not simply just oh
I happen to be Hindu or I happen to be
Buddhist or whatever now this it's much
deeper than that in our in our theology
in our Akita
likewise I think the issue here is that
when you talk about fear
and is fear always necessarily connected
to being some sort of dictator a
dictator Rules by their Neffs they rule
by oppressing people the fear that
people get from a dictator is because of
the oppression the Injustice that they
feel right but if you live in a
civilized society if you live in a
society that grants Justice
right the type of fear that is there the
type of fear of violating the law that
is more like a fear of violating your
own morality your own principles the
things that you agree with a violating
truth
so you should fear fearing a law fearing
falling into falsehood fearing violating
moral
um uh morality that should be that's a
healthy fear that's a correct fear that
is a just fear that we should have as
Muslims so just because we are told that
we should fear Allah we should fear
being punished this doesn't necessitate
that Allah is a dictator right it
doesn't necessitate that at all I mean
you live in a society right now are
there not rules that you agree to are
there not punishments that you agree to
do you not believe that murderers should
be killed do you not believe rapists
should be jailed do you not believe
these things should they not fear those
things should you not fear those things
for yourself
you agree with that fear you accept that
fear because that is a righteous fear
so let's not assume that fear is is
similar to tyranny or to oppression
there are various forms so when we say
fear Allah I'm not saying fear Allah
because of an oppressive sentiment we're
saying fear Allah because that is the
truth and as a human being not just as a
Muslim but as a human being you should
fear being upon falsehood
you should fear being against the truth
right so we say well well this person
does Good Deeds but if they do not good
do good deeds based on the right
intention if they do good deeds based on
falsehood is it really a good deed
because Islam is not simply about action
it's also about your intention it's
about where you're coming from your
motivation
Allah gave you your talents he gave you
your intellect he gave you your morality
and you're going and if somebody's going
to go in the afterlife and said no I did
it myself that is a profound form of
arrogance I deserve to go to heaven I
don't it doesn't matter what truth I was
upon I deserve because I offended poor
person
there has to be a difference this this
sentiment and I'm not saying you
necessarily a sister but I'm saying the
sentiment is is almost like a very
post-modern one that the truth doesn't
matter what matters is your actions but
it's the truth that defines the value of
our actions in reality it is not
ourselves
because if it's Society in ourselves
then we are saying that we are God we're
Allah that we are equivalent that we are
putting ourselves as partners to him
that we can judge what is valuable
and I think that is a big problem so yes
I do believe yes that as somebody who
knows the truth deserves to be punished
for it they deserve to be punished
because that is the very Foundation of
everything that they are as a human
being
so that's how I would say it and you
know I hope you didn't take offense to
what I said but please try to re-examine
these things try to think in a more
balanced Manner and you'll see what I'm
saying is is not off the it's not off
any sort of manhedge or anything you'll
understand